but where did you grow up mississauga
ontario canada and i still live there
now
oh really oh that's awesome well yeah it
hadn't been that long i guess you're
only 19.
um did you start out doing you know
musical theater anything there like
plays or anything yeah i
only started doing theater when i was in
grade 10 because i just wanted something
to do after school
yeah but i did start singing since i was
in grade three
but i had extreme stage fright i just
was like no i can't sing in front of
people like
ah that was scary so on stage and my mom
and my dad and my brother my grandma my
grandpa would come and watch me
and my mom would call me out and say i
know you're lip-syncing because you're
not even lip-syncing the right words
oh cause it was sort of embarrassing and
if you look at old videos it's just like
what is this kid doing
what is this kid doing we all did those
things you're fine you should have seen
my routine to win dove's cry by press
so it's not good um we actually have a
clip of you and i love it so i'm gonna
show it do it
do it do it i'm ready
[Music]
i mean we would have been friends just
from this video you're doing chicago
which is pretty funny considering the
material of the show and you're so young
it was awesome that was truly i was like
this is it like this is like the peak of
my career i finally like got a lead role
you know i was like wow this is going to
be the best that
dance in particular i was scared because
i was like ooh there's a lot of dancing
you know like
damn like catherine zeta jones did it
great in the movie but like you look
great
and then yeah i was like maybe maybe i
might be a little bit funny
like i think i might have the skill of
comedy
potentially i don't know the timing is
there
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever
[Music]